- Ça fait un an et demi que
pour la banlieue et ils ne
reviendraient pas en arrière.
CÉDRIC BÉLANGER
- Le grand événement
déclencheur, ça a été quand
on a appris qu'on allait
avoir un deuxième enfant.
- La nature est à proximité,
les enfants ont maintenant
une cour pour jouer,
tout comme les parents.
Mais surtout, ils ont plus
- Évidemment, bien, notre maison
est plus grande, fait que,
t'sais, pour être une petite
lleurs
autonomes, donc on travaille
souvent souvent souvent de la m,
c'est sûr qu'on se pile..
- L'exode des Montréalais vers
d'autres régions de la province
s'est accéléré avec la pandémie.
L'an dernier, la m
perdu plus de 48 000 résidents.,
les Laurentides en ont gagné
plus de 12 000, Lanaudière
et l'Estrie plus de 8000
et la Montérégie plus de 6000.
La Gaspésie et le Bas-Saint-
Laurent ont chacune accueilli un
millier de nouveaux arrivant
sa conjointe Sarah Gagnon-Piché.
- Puis, on a décidé de sauter,
sauter dans le vide un peu.
- Charles, qui avait perdu son
emploi l, a pu réaliser
son rêve de démarrer sa ferme
biologique. Mais c'est aussi
les prix élevés de l'immobil
poussé le couple à s'établ
près de Carleton-sur-Mer.
CHARLES MOISAN-WILLIS
- On sentait que ça nous
aurait enlevé de la latitude,
puis il y avait pas
cette contrainte-là en Gaspésie
ou, en t eu
une grande augmentation dans
la valeur immobilière, ça reste.
- Habituellement, l'immigration
arrive ison
de la pandémie, ce n'est
pas le cas cette fois.
de 47 000 résidents de moins
que l'an dernier. La croissance
économique pourrait en souffrir.
CHANTAL ROUTHIER,
- Lorsqu'on est en hausse,
qu'on acvantage
d'habitants, ça crée une demande
pour lese baisse
de population, bien, on s'attend
plutôt à l'effet inverse.
al mise
sur des logements abordables
et adaptés aux familles.
DOMINIQUE OLLIVIER, prés. comité
exécutif, Ville de Montréaldanst
se développer et on le voit
en Europe. Donc, c'est sûr
que le rêve américain du petit
bungalow est toujours attray
- Mais pour bien des
Montréalais, avec la pandémie
et les confinements,
le petit bungalow de banlieue
n'a jamais été aussi séduisant.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, Mon